well prisons have become one of the
flash points of the virus with riots
breaking out in Italy and thousands of
inmates being freed in Iran the prison
officers Association has thousands of
members across the UK's prison system
and their general secretary Steve Gillen
joins us now thank you so much for being
with us today
how worried are you about what
coronavirus could mean for our prisons
well this is unprecedented and it's not
just for our prisoners as for the staff
our brave workforce PR way members that
work in prisons up and down the country
and indeed in the NHS setting I've been
around the criminal justice system now
for 30 years and this is one of the most
critical issues going and I'm pleased to
say that we're working constructively
with government and with employer I've
had meetings with the Director General
Phil Koppel and I spoke to him on the
phone yesterday
and we've been updated as regular as can
because it's a moving situation and of
course by the nature of Prisons you have
a large number of people in relatively
close proximity to each other
Iran is freed tens of thousands of
prisoners because of this fear of
coronavirus spreading through our
prisons is that the kind of thing that's
in the contingency plans in the UK well
not as yet but previous governments have
done what was called an executive
release of prisoners that may come in
the future to free up spaces in prison
what does it mean does that mean like a
temporary release where they're
monitored and then brought back in later
it could mean that or that the Secretary
of State has the powers to look at low
risk category prisoners and just release
them as that executive it could well be
so for example at the moment in the
openness day which is known as the
category D estate there's about 4,000
prisoners in that now at the moment some
prisoners are being isolated who are
showing signs of the virus no one to my
knowledge F as a
this morning has actually been tested
positive but they are been isolated in
single sail accommodation now we all
know that prisons are grossly
overcrowded that can only happen for a
period of time staff as well my members
PR way members I mean prison officers
and operational support grades and all
those who work in prisons sometimes
wholly not recognized for the valuable
work that they do and this is an
opportunity to recognize the braveness
of those frontline staff who themselves
could be put at risk now I'm pleased to
say that we're working hand in glove
with employer and government I've
written to Robert Buckland offering him
a round table not just with ourselves
but with the Police Federation as all
the applied well he's not he's not
responded as yet but I'm hoping in the
coming days that he does because we've
said this is an opportunity for
government such as him
the Home Secretary pretty Patel and the
prime minister himself to talk to us
about our knowledge of the criminal
justice system I mean a couple of things
just to unpick from what you were saying
there firstly this idea that prisoners
obviously I guess if you show signs of
coronavirus or other owners will have to
self isolate and only so many single
vacancy styles there can you see other
buildings for example being taken over
to be used to isolate people it's not
been discussed with roses yet there
we've got more meetings coming in the
coming weeks and I suppose this is a
moveable feast if it takes off in
prisons then that's where absolutely
everywhere will have to be worked out we
don't want a situation like Italy and I
think communication with the men and
women prisoners and the youngsters in
our care is paramount
were got to converse with them properly
but got to converse with the families
and make sure that everybody's safe
because you're right other buildings
could be looked at for it so for example
in the past when
the prison service has been overcrowded
they've had to commandeer prison ships
and things that and make them safe and
so forth so I wouldn't rule anything out
at this moment in time but that the
welfare of those in our care is
paramount the welfare of staff is
paramount people we can't just send
prisoners home to self isolate that's
one of those occupations along with the
NHS I'm nurses you can't just say go
home because they've got to be at work
so we'll be looking for investment from
the government as well but I can I can
talk about those things directly what
the Secretary of State when it comes to
meet me well you need more prison
officers potentially then if a large
number of people are going to be at home
there is no doubt in my mind we will
need to up and say that for the last ten
years anyway but in particular with this
situation that we're in yeah I don't
want to make political points out of it
but we are under resourced you know I
want a proper package put in place for
prison officers operational support
grades we might have to have a budget
from government there increases for
overtime and things of that as and when
you need more money staff folk sick
because there will there is no doubt
about that at the moment some people are
safe self isolating Ella staff the the
figures that I've got as of yesterday
was in total 113 nationally and there's
some 75 prisoners in isolation at this
moment although none of them tested
positive this year and then just finally
you're talking about the welfare of
prisoners as well I mean in Italy we've
seen riots breaking out we've seen very
sadly some deaths because of drug
overdoses if people are being forced to
stay on their own visits are being
restricted this is going to have a big
impact on a group of people a section of
the population who already may have
mental health problems Sophia you're
absolutely right there's many vulnerable
cases within prisons of mental health as
you said of drug addiction even
prisoners that are aged 70 in over
that's increasing so we've got about
2,000 of them in a population at the
moment of course nobody wants to see
disturbances and riots of the scale that
was seen in Italy and that's why a
communication proper screening education
of both staff and prisoners in relation
to this is paramount and it's why my
union has taken on board to work
constructively with government and the
employer all employers because we are
the largest trade union in the criminal
justice sect and we take that very
responsibly and I'm sure with the
correct resources things will get bad
does it does no doubt about that but
it's preparing prisoners talking to them
to make sure they understand why certain
things have been done and it might be
done separately in different
establishments I don't think there'll be
a blanket ban on things or visits or
things like that but it could be
introduced gradually depending on how
severe is it certain prisons some big
questions there that need addressing
thank you very much coming the program
and outlining what the Prison Service is
doing to prepare much appreciate it
Thank You Sophie